[Musique]
et bien c'est un malin celui là
comment tu vas l'appli que des singes
vraiment tu crois
il nous a sauvé la vie il a été
remarquable
c'est toi tu es césar depuis le temps
qu'on recherche
dites à votre au colonel nous ne sommes
pas des bêtes sauvages
à
90 5 cibles acquise
[Musique]
préparez vous à vous battre
il montre au prix
ma maison
ma famille
et tous les jours des singes sont tués
humain est malade singes devient malin
alors humain tu sage mais n'est pas moi
je cours
il faut savoir renoncer à notre humanité
afin de pouvoir sauver l'humanité
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
la mener qu'à ces instants
si nous le perdons
planète deviendra
la planète des singes
[Musique]
ensemble
change
or
[Musique]